Here, the correct answer is our negative 5 halves and positive 2. Now that's
amazing if you got that correct. You've really gained steam in solving
quadratic equations. We start solving this equation by subtracting 10 from both
sides. This sets our quadratic equation equal to 0, and now we can try and
factor. We want to find factors of negative 20 that sum to positive 1. These
factors are positive 5 and negative 4. We use these coefficients to rewrite our
middle term of x, and these factoring by grouping to get these factors. We set
each factor equal to 0, and then solve each equation for x. This gives us a
solution set of negative 5 halves and positive 2. I hope this was a great
refresher on solving quadratic equations. In the upcoming lessons, we'll find
other ways to solve these quadratics. Sometimes they aren't always factorable.